teddy bridgewater has been traded to the
nfl's equivalent of tibet depending upon
which day it is in the winter time it
could be 70 one day and six feet of snow
the next 10 what is this
[Music]
i was like what's going on
that was awesome
danny bridgewater
now a member of the denver broncos this
was one of those and i'm sure we had the
conversation right after sam darnold was
traded to the panthers this was an
obvious destination george payton gm of
the broncos was in minnesota when they
drafted teddy bridgewater seven years
ago when they swoop back in to the
bottom of the round they love him there
they love him everywhere he's been yeah
sure they don't love drew locke they got
him for a sixth round pick and
they're only paying four and a half
million dollars because the panthers are
paying seven million to pick up the
sixth round pick and unload the 10
million they would have owed teddy
bridgewater if they'd cut him so
win-win win
teddy's got a new team bronco's got a
new quarterback panthers have one less
quarterback and both teams are still in
play for first rounders at eight and
nine respectively which like all right
i'm gonna start there i don't buy that i
mean i i don't buy that i really don't i
mean i know that's what they're trying
to get you i know they're trying to get
you know everybody want everybody's
taking a quarterback in the draft the
whole draft is taking the quarterback i
mean everybody yeah trade up we're
taking a quarterback i mean listen if
that's what they did if that's what they
do and they do take a quarterback
tomorrow i mean yeah that'll make no sen
no sense to me with either team the
panthers or the broncos just go hey
let's just more assets to the
quarterback position quarterback
quarterback i would think that they made
this trade to now free themselves up
officially to draft the player they
think they need the most at number nine
with the denver broncos but like mike
you said it right this is not a shocker
it's not i think the money you you were
on this all along the money was the big
the big problem with the teddy
bridgewater situation you know guys he's
not going to be a definitive starter
he's gonna have to battle it out with a
drew lock so they don't want to give him
starting money and then have the guy
that you know might beat him out and be
the starter you know of course making
minimum wage or a rookie minimum second
second round of the draft type money uh
and of course you know they know that
carolina wants to get rid of teddy
bridgewater but i think the points you
made are real like yeah bridgewater came
from minnesota
from where george payton was he
understands what he's all about
and i think it also is like
the perfect guy to go along with drew
locke for vic fangio if i'm if i'm in
vic fangio shoes right you got a guy in
drew locke that we see talent he could
be something but he also could be a guy
that's careless and throws a lot of
interceptions or like that and then it's
like okay if he does that hey
we got teddy bridgewater who knows how
to play like the game through the
defensive angle like he did in minnesota
with zimmer and control the ball and
don't turn it over for so from that
standpoint it makes a lot of sense for
the broncos
yeah absolutely and chris i thought of
something as you were
being a little bit snarky yes about the
expectation by some including our own
peter king that five quarterbacks will
be drafted in the top ten you've got
three in your mock draft you've got
you've i got you three in your marketing
i got you guys
i was thinking of mine right
you got three you got four you got four
peter's got five i got three
i wonder how much though
because clearly the panthers could still
yeah go quarterback at eight right and
the broncos could still go quarterback
at nine
i wonder how much of
rolling the dice on that quarterback
that may be there
how much is about
maybe we get a franchise guy that is the
answer to the position for the next 15
years and how much of it is
if we don't take this guy
and he ends up being a superstar
we're never going to hear the end of it
like how much of that go it's got it
yeah you got so many hours of build up
to the draft and all you got to do is
look at ryan pace and the chicago bears
and see what they have been hounded by
for the last four years because they
traded up a spot to get mitch trubisky
they took the lemon off the showroom
floor yeah and left the two high
performance vehicles on the lot
you i think that's part of your
motivation we need a franchise
quarterback david tepper i'm telling you
back seat of his suv all or nothing on
amazon go find it it was the season
obviously with the panthers the league
is set up for everyone to be eight and
eight yeah but with a good coach
gm and quarterback
that's how you skew it in your favor you
let that quarterback stay on the board
and somebody else gets him somebody from
your division gets him somebody you
compete with gets him and he ends up
being great
i know that makes it even worse i know i
think than taking him and having him end
up being well you could play that you
could play there's two sides to that
story too though i could also go to
david tepper and the broncos and go look
at the story of sam darnold there you go
maybe that's why you don't just take the
quarterback to think oh i gotta take him
he's the franchise and all that too you
could certainly like argue that side of
the you know example to go along with it
you're right it's a tough decision for
the denver broncos and all that i think
what could be different though right as
like you compare it to the bears and all
of that
you know this is like take the
quarterback or you don't take the
quarterback right and i don't know if
you'll it'll be held against you right
we don't talk about the 49ers passing up
patrick mahomes very often
right or a lot of you have though i know
we have we talked about it more than
most we do right or the other teams that
were in the draft that also passed them
up i mean you know what i mean i know
you and i do but it doesn't they had
black bortles they had black portals
yeah right why did you want to upgrade
from the 70th best quarterback in the
end hey when you got him you'd have you
never looked to upgrade but that's where
you know now that's what that's what i i
mean to me that's uh
you threw me off track there but that
that
but go ahead i think what you're what
you're saying is it's better to not take
a quarterback
the potential franchise guy what made it
worse for the bears is they picked the
wrong they went they picked the wrong
guy yes yeah exactly so so really if
lansing fields are trickling down the
board if it goes trevor lawrence zach
wilson justin uh mack jones one two
three and fields and lancer there at
eight
that's and you're and you're
the panthers
and you take one of the two and the
other one ends up being much better
that's when you get yourself that's what
you get
exactly that's that's the jam you gotta
worry about where you go man i hope we
took the right one i hope we didn't let
the guy go that's gonna be the superstar
and you know we're gonna have egg in our
face over all of this you know three
years from now and everybody's gonna be
telling us all about that but hey i
certainly can see that possibility of
where lance and fields are on the uh on
the board still sitting there at number
eight and that's to me when the action
starts to as far as okay yeah there's
the possibility of carolina maybe
drafting a quarterback as silly as i
think that is
but but then it's also i think the time
we look at to go okay
do the do the new england patriots come
up to take a tray lance does washington
come up to take one of the two are the
bears gonna think about making a move i
would say that's about the area where if
they fall you're gonna start to see a
lot of phone calls and actions about you
know their service and i think
especially trey lance i think if trey
lance falls to the bottom part of the
top ten i think there's gonna be far
greater action for him than over justin
fields
i really do um i have some knowledge of
that but also i have my belief through
my studies and things like that to go
along with it
the problem is with 32 teams in the
league it's impossible to know what they
all think and i can't recall a
quarterback
where there has been a more wildly
diverging swing you've got some people
who think that fields should go over
zack wilson it too and then you've got
others who think that this is a guy who
could plummet all the way to the bottom
of the round as you do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports